Hey, Will, what's your middle name? My middle name? Yeah, quick. It's Emerson. That's right. You don't sound sure. It is Emerson. No, no, no.
I'm not. I just thought that you knew. I thought you knew everything about me. No, I didn't know. I don't. Sean, your middle name? Patrick. Patrick.
Really? Oh, yeah, you're right. Sean Patrick Hayes. Yeah. And JB, what's yours? Let me guess yours. It's something, it's very, it's like. Here it comes.
Hurtful. No. Careful. It's my dad's first name. So if he's listening, careful. Oh, missing? No. No, I know what it is.
I know what it is. It's. That's Sean, you dick. It's Kent. My dad's name is Kent. Kent. Kent. You can't ever forget it. So you're Kent. I know what it is. I know what it is. It's... That's Sean, you dick. My dad's name is Kent. Kent.
Kent. You can't ever forget it. So you're Kent Jason Bateman? No, Jason Kent Bateman. Dumb fuck. Middle name. Alright, welcome to Smart List. I never showed you this video. I have a video to show you. Hang on. Open the book.
Oh wait, here it is. Oh yeah, have you seen this? Is that you and Scotty? God, I hope that's you and Scotty. Yeah, it is. Is it? Yeah. Why, where, when? Listener, we have Sean and Scotty
in one of these self-propelled locomotives going down a track. Yeah, it's awesome. It's called Rail. Redwood Forest. Like a little paddle boat you'd ride in a lake on. Yeah, it's through the forest. It's called Railbiking.
Where was that? Was that on Second Honeymoon? That was up north, north of San Francisco. We went last weekend, was it? Or two weekends ago or something like that. Why were you guys up there messing around on the trail? Because I saw it like on Instagram or something, this rail bike that you just pedaled on the railroad tracks.
So you're like Scottie Pack and overnight pack? Yeah, we just went up there, we just did it. We gotta do this? Yeah, it's amazing. I can't imagine being as spontaneous and happy-go-lucky as that. Just like you're scrolling through it. Well, it was planned a little bit.
But it still came from just scrolling through Instagram. I'm like, hey, that looks fun. Hun, what are you doing next weekend? Why not? I mean, there's a whole world out there. You know what I mean? I just feel like it's so disruptive to pick up and leave the place there where you're settled.
I just have zero wanderlust. I'm not proud of it, but. You don't, huh? No. But you love the outdoors and stuff, don't you? It was so beautiful from the inside of an air-conditioned car. I was saying to you when we were flying in New York,
I was like, I point out the window, I go, there's a whole world out there. Yeah, exactly. I wanna get it, I was saying to somebody yesterday, I wanna get into the world, it's all I wanna do. Wouldn't it be fun to all go, the three of us, and our significant others to go, like do like an adventure like that,
just for like the weekend? Yeah, but can it be higher end than paddle boarding down a rail? It's not paddle boarding. Yes, we can do something a little more significant. You know, one of the things that we should talk about, but probably not on the podcast, but I'm going to do it anyway, is Sean and I were talking with the ladies, i.e. your wife, JB,
and my significant other, Alessandra, and the ladies. We can include Scottie in there as a second guy. Well, Scottie was there too, and then our other female friend who's an advisor to the podcast, so has a lot of opinions. She, she, she. Amanda.
No, no, no. No, the other one. Oh, that person, yes. And I said, I said, you know, we oughta go to, because they want us to come, then we can talk to our buddy, Mitch Rose, we oughta go to Australia at Christmas, which is their summer, which I've never done,
and do the tour and do like Sydney Opera House. I've never been. I would like to do that, but can we go, can we do, we did skiing last year, can we go beach this year? So this is what I was gonna say, we go there and then we do, we did skiing last year. Can we go beach this year? So this is what I was gonna say. We go there and then we do the beach. They don't have any beaches in Australia.
They don't have beaches. Are you crazy? No, it's all landlocked. And we go to like the Gold Coast somewhere and we do like a week of like incredible beach. Why do we have to be working when we're vacationing? We do a little bit of both. But my thing, but Will, my thing is you get the beach here where in, on the West Coast,
wouldn't you want to go somewhere different? Without the 17 hour flight. What beach? What beach? What do you mean? There's, have you looked at a map? It's all, we're on the edge of the water. You mean the California beaches? I'm talking about tropical beaches.
First of all, Sean, nice try. You might as well still live in Chicago. Okay? Cause you go, you go from your fucking house to fucking Larchmont and that's right Give me a fucking you could live it could be anywhere. You might as well move into a mall. I mean Inside okay, then you and Scottie can do the fucking laps to the food court What I'm suggesting is I'm so white it's true
We go to Australia or somewhere like that and we go somewhere that we wouldn't normally go That's out of our comfort zone. That's why and then we do a full beach experience. I actually would like that I would like to I've never been on I love I love Australia like I can't even we do have to go somewhere But but wait guys listen, I don't want to keep our fancy guests waiting So rude to talk about I know the gas but you guys she's sitting in there waiting from overseas She's in the UK right now. What? Yes, but you'd never know with her flawless American accent that she does. She can act,
she can sing. Boy, can she sing. Wow. And in her most recent film. You wrote that part too. I wrote all of this. And in her most recent film, she can even swim the English channel, which I tried to watch last night, but the links they send you, I forget it. This effervescent young lady's middle name is Jazz. Remember we were just talking about our middle names? And she has been a hot ticker. Annette Benning or Jodie Foster, which one?
Nope, it's not either. And she has been a hot ticket in the film industry for almost a decade, starting when she joined one of the biggest movie franchises of all time. Apparently her Duolingo score in French is pretty impressive too. It's the radiant Daisy Ridley.
Daisy Ridley! I know Daisy a tiny bit. Hi Daisy! Oh my god, what time is it there? It's 6.27. It's not that crazy, it's 6.27. What do you think, she's on Mars? Daisy Ridley, welcome to Smart Listen. I'm so excited to talk to you and meet you. I'm a massive fan. It's so weird. I've listened to it so much and I'm like, I'm here. Have you really? No you haven't. Of course. I'm sorry it's sounding a little bit like
drive-time radio this morning. We're a little too chatty. Sorry. We'll calm down. We'll calm down. Daisy, do you think we should go to Australia for Christmas with our families? I got back from Australia ten days ago, shooting a movie there. Had a great time. Can't recommend it enough. Really? So what are you doing in England right now? Do you live there? I live here, yeah.
And you grew up there. Alright. So you're cozy at home right now? I'm cozy at home. And you grew up there? You grew up there, all right. So you're cozy at home right now? I'm cozy at home. I grew up here. I've never actually lived anywhere else bar for work. I'm a real homebody. So like, I love London.
I always like- You find a nice place to stay there, Sean? I do know, the Whitby hotels are amazing. Right, anybody? No. I like the club. But London is great, I love it. I always wondered like what it would be,
like do you appreciate it like we appreciate it or are you just like, there's the big bang, there's the blah blah blah, I don't, you know, the history and it's so old and beautiful and gorgeous. Yeah, every time I go past the Houses of Parliament, I'm like, oh, and then I walk into town, parks are beautiful.
I mean, summer in London is really nice. So I'm very happy to be here right now. Have you ever desired to live somewhere else? Me and my husband were gonna move to LA for a few months just before lockdown. So we had like a place booked and everything. We were just gonna see what it was like for a few months. Try it on.
And then lockdown. Now, why were you gonna try it on? Were you getting. Now why were you going to try it on? Were you getting pressure from the adults in your life that say, can you please be closer to the studios? No, not at all. It was just, I guess, a curiosity. And then it didn't happen and then we didn't. But my husband, who is based on a true story, obviously... And his name is Tom and his last name is...
The best. The his name is Tom and his last name is? The best. Bademan. Yeah, I mean, does that just not roll right off the tongue? Tom Bademan. So because of that show, he's now lived there. Well, he's about to live there for the second time. So it's best of both worlds. So then what are you going to do?
Are you going to join him or are you gonna be busy on another project? How do you guys work all that stuff? We do what we can. And that's pretty nice. We do our best. That's pretty nice because Young Woman in the Sea now wonderfully has a theatrical release.
So I get to do some work for that in LA. So we'll be there together. That's so nice. And then, yeah. But we work it out pretty well. He's so good on that. It is called Based on a True Story. I know Sean and Will is probably in your queue there. Go ahead and enjoy that.
Thank you. It's on the Peacock. And you've got no skit in the game on this one? Oh yes, sure, no, sure I do. Oh, do you? Well, explain to us just for full disclosure. Well I get quite a bump if a couple more people start watching it, so we're just two away.
Wait, are you producing it? He's the executive producer of it, yeah. Oh I didn't know that. And I didn't, listen, is this your guest? I am not trying to get to my viewership. No, well we have to watch it. You kept winking at Daisy as if like prompt her. That's a tick, be sensitive.
That's a tick. Okay. Now listen, Daisy, be sensitive. That's a tick. Now listen, Daisy, tell us about growing up there because you, first of all, five girls in one family. Oh yes, but my two half-sisters are a lot older because there's an age gap with my parents, so we didn't grow up with them, but three of us was still a lot. That's a lot, That's a lot.
That's a lot. And father was a photographer, mother worked at a bank, nobody else kind of had the bug to get into the business. Well my mom actually worked in picture publicity for a long time. I think worked on Friends. She worked on some really cool stuff. Oh really? What did she do with Friends?
Well she was the picture publicist at Channel 4. She worked on some really cool stuff. What did she do with Friends? She was the picture publicist at Channel 4. So when all those big shows were going on and she was doing the pictures. That show was so related because we all knew that thing of when your job's a joke, you're broke, your love life's DOA. You feel like you're always stuck in second gear. It hasn't been your day, your week, your month, or even your year. Can we hold there for a second? So Will, you're familiar with those lyrics because you watched that show religiously? No, that song is omnipresent.
It was in the 90s. It's not. Inescapable. No, no, no. It's only inescapable if you watch the show religiously and this is a big, big thing I'm learning about you is that you're a closet friends fan. I wanna say closet, I love friends. I love the friends.
Daisy, you love friends too, right? Don't stop me burning. I do love friends, yeah. Yeah, no. All the Brits love friends. I love all the friends and I love the show and I love our friends. I haven't watched, I'm embarrassed to say
I haven't actually watched a ton of the show, but I know that song because it was everywhere. But that's your ringtone, I guess. No, but I have dropped that on the girls before. I have done that to Jen and Gunn. Like, I know, I feel you, you know, your job's a joke, you're broke, your love life's DOA, And she's like, fuck off. I'm sorry Daisy.
Wait, wait Daisy, let's go back. So your mom worked in publicity, maybe did some stuff for Channel 4 or something. But so what was the moment you go, you're like, mommy, I need to do that. Oh my God. I can't do that nowadays. You did, you did.
Mommy. Yeah, what was the first time? Well, I was at primary school. You can't do that nowadays. You did. You did. I'm age. Yeah, what was the first time? Well, I was at primary school. I was slightly misbehaving. What? And we used to go, because three girls, you wanna be- Is this the Tring Park school, or is this before Tring Park?
This is before Tring Park. Oh, sure. Because, guys, just so you know, Tring Park, it looks like Downton Abbey. It's like unbelievable. Oh, yeah. I can't believe you went to school there. Oh, yeah, it was literally, and I'm a huge Harry Potter fan.
It was literally Harry Potter. I love it. I was quite naughty at school as a child. And then my mom, to keep us busy in the summer holidays, used to send us to this music thing where kids would go and, I guess sort of like camp for you guys. And I had a friend there who went to boarding school. I was like, boarding school sounds amazing.
And she thought if I was busy, I would behave better. And so I auditioned for this performing arts school, having never really done performing arts, and then ended up staying there from nine till 18. Wow. So over the course of that time, fell in love with all of the performing arts. That's amazing. Can I ask you what your flavor of misbehavior was?
Well, I mean, I can't have been that bad if I was fairly young, but just if I wasn't busy enough, I would start distracting other kids and that sort of stuff. With humor or throwing shit at them? I don't know. Asking for a friend. I had a few different encouragements not to return, shall we say. And I kind of mixed it up quite a bit.
I went to boarding school and I was not kicked out. I make this distinction. I was asked not to return. Yeah. Very good. That's what they're like. My first ever job actually, I was asked not to return for the second week.
It was this, it was honestly fucking soul-crushing. Really? Wait, wait, wait, what happened? Well the worst thing was, it was like a workshop thing to do a play. It wasn't even a play. It was like a table read or whatever. It wasn't even recorded. What? Yeah, so we were doing the workshop for two weeks and on the Friday they were like, you
don't need to come back next week. Oh my God. It was hideous. And obviously, like, I had taken time out of my job because at the time I was working at a pub and I thought, oh my God, because I was terrible, honestly. Really? No, I don't believe that. No, seriously.
They were like, you bring nothing to this. Were you good at working at the pub? I actually was, yeah. Really? Was that pouring the, doing the, what's it called? The draft. Doing the pints. The draft, yeah.
Doing that and then you do the little haircut off the top of it? A well poured, actually I shouldn't say that. I mean, pouring pints in London, you don't do that thing. Oh, why? Or you just let it drip over. I don't know. You've got a cascade. But you were good.
If somebody wanted to come in for a cheeky pint, you could just serve them up nicely and then send them on their way. Cheeky pint. Yeah. I actually had a very strange thing recently. I was in the,th arrondissement of Paris in a hotel doing some press for a tiny movie I made a couple years ago. And a guy at breakfast comes over and he goes, are you Daisy?
I was like, yeah, you're so familiar. I used to serve him at the pub. Oh, wow. And he's a photographer, did a book on Bowie and was there promoting the book. And he was like, literally the last time I saw you you were pouring me a pint saying oh I have this audition hopefully it will go well and it was Star Wars. And that was the last time I saw him.
That's crazy. What's Bowie? David Bowie. Oh Bowie. Bowie. Bowie. A lot of Brits say Bowie. Oh I didn't hear that.
I'm here to translate for you Daisy. Wait so that's what I want to ask for you, Daisy. Wait, so that's what I want to ask. You dropped out of college to take Star Wars, right? I dropped out of university, yeah. But I mean, it wasn't like you had to be enrolled and be on campus sort of thing. Right. You could do it online or something. Yes.
But was there any hesitation at all? It wasn't Trump Trump University was it? There is a class action so you can get involved Was there any hesitation at all in Accepting that role at such a young age because being in school or whatever for fear that it might like did you even think about my Changed your way of life forever or were you more like, get me the hell out of here, I want to work?
You know what I mean? Like did you ever think about like how much it would change your life? Well JJ is so convincing, you know? I mean you get inside those eyes, that vortex there, JJ will talk you into anything, right? You melt, you melt. I actually have a hilarious text from him.
The best. He used to say to me, your eyes are so big. So I was watching something I did last year and my eyes are so massive in the thing. I took a picture and sent it to him and he's literally sent me a birthday text with just like my eyes everywhere. That's funny.
There was zero hesitation now. I was desperate for the role and had been waiting seven months from my first audition. So I was like, give me a chance. You auditioned seven months before you got the yes? Yeah, I did a number of auditions over a seven-month period. Yeah. Oh my God.
And did you just tell the pub, I can't work anymore because I'm now I'm gonna be doing Star Wars. See you guys later. I said, I've got a job. So I'm gonna have to go bye-bys. Really? Go bye-bys. Yeah, but then I didn't tell. Did they say, why are you speaking to us
like a four-year-old? Like they didn't say. Yeah. Have to make bye-bys. They were like, what's wrong with you? Yeah, no, I was just like, oh, I just got a job, I have to go. And no one knew what was going on for a few months anyway.
I didn't tell anyone by my family. What part of town was that pub in just in case they're listening? It's the Union Tavern in Westbourne Park. Union Tavern in Westbourne Park. Why? Why? Do you know it? Are you going to go visit it? I'm going to go there in two weeks. When I go over there, I'm going to go say hi for Daisy. By the way, it's a really gorgeous pub. It's right on the canal. It's right by Portobello. Yeah.
I love Portobello on a Saturday. On a Saturday. One of the funniest things I've ever seen in my life was a guy, we were walking down Portobello Road on a Saturday. Who's we? Who's we? I guess it was Chappie and me probably. Yeah, there we go.
Got it. But, because he lives up in Queens Park and so we're just walking. No, I know. Just need to get Chappie in one more time. I know. And so this is my friend, Mark Chappell Chappie. They know he's a friend of the podcast. That's two. That's three. Yep. And so we're walking along, Mark Chappell Chappell. They know he's a friend of the podcast. That's two, that's three.
Yep. And so we're walking along and we see a guy, beautiful Saturday, and we see a guy in like an orange, like an orange sherbert colored Lamborghini with the top down. And you know those, you know that road is like so packed on a Saturday, right? Like you can, and those stoplights,
like just before you start getting down into Portobello Road. And this guy comes along, he's at the stoplight in this orange thing, and everybody's looking, and then the light goes green. And he guns it, like, whoo, whoo! And he's only got about 70 yards to go, and the next light is red. He has to stop. And everybody collectively laughed at this guy in his face.
It was so good. It was so, so good. Anyway, Union Tavern, I'm gonna... OK. I just spat this guy in his face. It was so good. It was so, so good. Anyway, Union Tavern, I'm gonna... We'll be right back. Viori listener. Viori is the ultimate destination for high quality and stylish and sustainable active wear. Everything is designed to work out in, but it doesn't look or feel like it. So comfortable, you'll wanna wear it all the time. Honestly, it's comfier than whatever you're wearing
right now. Now, I am truly a Viori wearer. Mostly I do the workout shorts. Very comfortable, and I also have a little bit of a like a jumper, like a jacket type of thing with the cool little circle V logo on it that I think is pretty sporty. If you see me on the street and you disagree, let me know. Otherwise, I'll take your smiles as a confirmation. Viori is an investment in your happiness listener and they're hooking up smart list listeners
with 20% off your first purchase at Viori.com slash smart list. That's V U O R I dot com slash smart list. Not only will you receive 20% off your first purchase, but you'll also enjoy free shipping on any U S orders over $75 and free returns. Go to Viori.com slash smartlisten to discover the versatility of Viori clothing. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, this year's gone so quickly.
I mean, I'm proud so far that I am, I think I'm slightly better at being a friend or father or husband this year. I've been trying every year to be better at that stuff. But you know, if you're coming up a little short or you think you're coming up a little short, I mean, better help would be a great idea. I mean, when life goes so fast, it is important to take a moment to celebrate your wins and make adjustments for the rest of the year. Therapy can help you take stock of your progress
and set achievable goals for the next six months. If you're thinking about starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge.
Take a moment, visit betterhelp.com slash smartlis today to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelp, H-E-L-P dot com slash smartlis. Thank you to FanDuel for supporting this episode of SmartList. Summertime means baseball, the NBA Finals, and more. And you can bet it all on FanDuel. Right now, new customers get $200 in bonus bets with any winning $5 bet. That's $200 you can use to bet everything from the finals MVP to who's going to hit one
out of the park. You know when you flip a coin sometimes, you know, you can bet, is it gonna be heads? Is it gonna be tails? That's sometimes fun, you guys. You know, you don't have to take big risks in this world to really have fun. Sometimes it can just be a simple 50-50 proposition, you know,
and I'll bet you FanDuel can handle that. So if you want to have some coin flipping contests, try FanDuel. Huh? Visit FanDuel.com, slash, smart list and add a big win to your summer bucket list. FanDuel, America's number one sportsbook. 21 plus exclusions apply. See show notes for full disclaimer. All right, back to the show.
So you didn't tell your family when you first got it. Or you only told your family, nobody else? I only told my family. Wow, and you just, just because you didn't want what? Why weren't you like, why didn't you tell the world, like, oh my God, everybody, I got this fucking thing? Oh no, I wasn't allowed. Oh thing? Oh no, I wasn't allowed. Oh.
No, no, I wasn't allowed. And I took that very seriously. I know John Boyega said he got in a cab and told the cabbie straight away, but I was like so scared to say anything. No, I told him, my dad was asleep when I told him and he went, Jesus Christ. And I told my mom and sister when I walked in.
Yeah. Yeah, and then I kept it secret. I mean, it completely changed your whole life. It's so exciting. I'm obviously, if you listen, and these guys are so sick of me, and you're probably so sick of talking about it, I'm sorry. But she's a massive fan of the franchise and you. No, of course.
He wants to know, he's too embarrassed to ask, which of the planets is real what's your favorite planet who is your favorite slash one of our I'm excited for the new one you're gonna do a new one or three or we don't know yet but you're playing right I'm doing one for now. Can you tell us anything about it? I can tell you, I was surprised. I made a movie. Well that's not enough information, I wanna know what happens.
Well I made a movie with my husband called MacPy. And I had one day off shooting and I was invited to breakfast with Cathy Kennedy. And I was like, true. Because we occasionally take a meal together. And for my sister Tracy, Cathy Kennedy produces those films. Yes, ahead of Lucasfilm.
Thanks, Sean. There you go, that's my sister. And I thought we were just having breakfast. And my friend was like, oh, imagine if they're doing another rating. And I was like, I doubt it. And halfway through breakfast, she said, we are, how do you feel? And I was like, I doubt it. And halfway through breakfast, she said, we are, how do you feel?
And I was surprised. So cool. But it, yeah, yeah, it's very cool. Different writer, different director. It will be quite a different feeling, I imagine. Who's writing, who's directing? Yeah, who's writing, who's directing? Steven Knight is writing.
Oh, nice. And directing is Sharmine Oboy-Chinoy who has made some unbelievable documentaries. And it's very exciting and I shall be reading a script soonish. That's so cool. Do you have to go to like a secret vault to read the script? No, I think I'm going to, not a secret vault. Maybe they'll just send it to you.
No, I think I'll have to go somewhere. Will you send it to me after you read it? Yeah, just double click that over. I'll take a picture of every script page. Please. And a PDF, please. So I'd imagine that you are somewhat kind of self-prepared for all of the attention, the profile, after Star Wars came out, but did it match your preparation and expectations?
Tell me how you dealt with being, you know, unable to walk down the street overnight. I didn't know what to expect, and everyone had made it out to be crazy, crazy, crazy. And obviously, as you all know, when things come out, there's a flurry of activity and then things sort of calm down again. So it was confronting because it was strange initially for people to want to chat because I'm not that chatty. So I'd be like, and then it sort of goes away again.
But people are very nice and yeah, it sort of took its time to come. Yeah, but tell me like, I mean, I've said this before to other people like, like other people who've been in the franchise, but like JJ, or like not JJ, but people who've been in the franchise, like JJ, not JJ, but other actors have been in stars, is like Adam Driver, whoever, what is it like to be,
like if it was me, I'd wake up every day and go, I can't fucking believe I'm in this movie. Like how do you, at such a young age, cope with or stuff your excitement? Like you can't show. You'd have a tough time, they'd have a tough time shooting around your boner, I guess. Oh my god.
No full stop. Wide angle, wide angle. Guys, we're gonna go a little tighter again. We're gonna pick up all the wides at the end of the shoot. You guys, fucking first six weeks are just coverage. No, but like, at such a young age, that's so funny. At such a young age where you just, I know you can't like, holy shit. And then John Williams, talk about that.
Like writing, you have your own theme written by John Williams, which is- I mean, my, one of my favorite things ever is me and John Williams are pen pals. Oh, wow. That's so cool. Yeah, I really, that's crazy. And what was it like to hear that for the first time? That was crazy. I mean, so much of it was honestly overwhelmed at the beginning. I can't remember a large chunk of everything.
Ah, shit. But, I mean, even with filming, I can't remember, like, specifics. But also I had a group of people to sort of hold on to. And JJ, as you all know, is amazing. JJ's okay. JJ's okay. Well, we don't want him to get too far over his keys because we know he's listening.
He's just like, JJ, cool it, all right? Just cool it. And then I was so, like, I was in awe, like, preparing for this to go through YouTube and hear your unbelievable singing voice. Like I don't know that a lot of people know that, that you can sing so, like how did you, when did you first realize that
and why haven't we seen more of that? Well, I have had no shame in asking anyone to put me in a musical. Like literally no shame. I've done it on national TV, everything. It's gonna happen. It's not happened yet. It will. No, the Barbara Streisand thing,
which is another crazy thing, there's occasionally I'm like, oh my God, that was JJ. JJ introduced the two of us. And initially I met her because she was meant to be doing Gypsy. So that whole thing was so, yeah, yeah. Oh wow. Yeah, so there was a potential of testing to be in it.
Oh wow. And I went to her house and it was, that was insane. I heard the house is crazy, like there's a mall underneath the house, like she has a shopping mall. Yeah, but I mean just sat with her, I was like, wow, you are Barbra Streisand. That is that sort of, you know, effervescence and power from someone is... Did you have to sing in front of her?
Well, we sang together. You recorded? Yeah, they recorded at the ballet from a chorus line. With Anne Hathaway. Huh. Yeah. It's a hard song to sing and you guys knocked it out of the park. It was so overwhelming and that weekend I also presented...
That was one of the craziest things. The film had come out, it was all nuts. And then I presented the Oscars with Dev Patel, which was wonderful. But the day before I had recorded with Barbra Streisand. And that weekend was one of those, what the fuck is going on? This is insane. That was one of those weekends. How'd old Tommy Bateman do through all that? Oh, we weren't together then.
Yeah. No? Really? No, we met on Murder on the Orient Express. What do you think he was doing that weekend? Yeah, I'll tell you what he was doing. He was learning his lines for Based on a Orient Express. What do you think he was doing that weekend? Yeah, I'll tell you what he was doing. Learn his lines for Based on a True Story. You can see it on Peacock. You think before they wrote it, you think he was... Of course.
All Batemans work ahead. So, Shawnee, let's ask her about Murder on the Orient Express and if she can give us any tips about... Hang on. Cool it, Will. You're not on this trip. Shaw and I are gonna go on the Orient Express at some point, and we'd like a little bit of research from you on that.
Are you kidding? You guys won't even go to fucking La Cienega. You think you're gonna go to the Orient Express? It's like five blocks away. If anybody's going, it's me, go ahead. Yeah, tell us about the Orient Express. And Patrick Doyle is a wonderful friend of mine. He did the music for that movie. Thanks for starting the interview for that. about the Orient Express. And Patrick Doyle is a wonderful friend of mine.
He did the music for that movie. Thanks for starting the interview for that. Thanks for the heads up, in case we bump into him. I wish I could tell you about the actual Orient Express. I got freebies, but I gave it to my parents. So they've been, and had the most amazing time. What did they say? I really want to do that. You're not coming.
I mean, it's unbelievable. You have to fully wear a suit to dinner, or, you know, evening attire. Sorry, Shonda has a question. No, not track suit. Keep going, Dizzy. LAUGHTER Wait, for what? You have to... You have to be... You have to be fancy. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, wait, listen to this. So, the last... So, the first time I was ever in London, like this is my last, Will's laughing. I'm just kidding. Will's having a tough time. Will's having a tough time. Jason keeps going, okay, okay. I mean, he's so kind of him to always prep us
for every sentence. Each one, here we go. But speaking of that, the first time I was ever in London. There's another one. What I just wanna say is, but wait, go ahead. But wait. I fucking love you. God damn it, I could do a whole day with you.
This is all gonna keep you cut. Not two, just one. Keep going. God, are you kidding? In a fish market. So listen. So here's my. Here it is, here's another one, so listen.
Nevermind, it's not gonna, so listen. Never mind. It's not gonna be that great a story. Don't key yourself up, just say the thing. Okay, the first time I was in London, I had to go out to... God, you feel so naked without the... I'm sorry, we'll get back to your career, Daisy. We're new at this, Daisy, sorry. Daisy's so sorry.
No, but take my dressing up. The first time I went to London, I went to this restaurant and they required a jacket for you to go sit down, like you're talking about the Art Express. And I didn't have one on, I had like a, I don't know what I had, like a dress. Should I take a guess what you had?
Hoodie, hoodie and a Chicago Cubs t-shirt. Yeah, with a cardigan underneath it. Exactly. I walk in and they're like, sorry sir, we can't serve you without a jacket. And so they said we have a closet full of jackets for you to choose from. And I was like, wait, what? And I'm like, the table we're sitting at
is three feet away from us. Can I just walk to the table and sit down please? Like, no, you have to pick a jacket. There are these jackets in storage for people who show up with no jacket. So I put this oversized jacket from the 1980s or 90s. And I go to- Completely ruining your outfit.
I don't, it was a long way to go for that story, sorry, Daisy. Wait, were you with Scotty? Yeah. Scotty had a jacket on? He did have a jacket on. You bet he did. Yeah.
He knows how to read. Anyway. Sorry, Daisy, Daisy, I'm so fucking sorry. This is just- Well, let's start over. I wanna know. Let's just start over. So, Murder on the Ornate Express, brilliant. I love that movie.
Sometimes I think about dying. I saw that fucking great American accent, great character. So into you. I can take my eyes off you every scene. Great story. Talk about the American accent, great character, so into you, I can take my eyes off you every scene. Talk about the American accent, Daisy. When was the first time that you can remember doing it? Maybe not even in a role. Do you remember the first time you tried it?
No, I mean, as Brits, the American accent, one thinks of with LA is the like, oh my God thing. Like that is the thing. But I actually met my... That's really accurate. Yeah, that is accurate. I met my dialect coach through Tom Holland, who has been a guest on this show.
Oh yes, we love Tom. Anytime a brick comes on, we always talk about American accents, because we're fascinated to hear ourselves. Well, his was so good, I was doing an English accent in that film, that in lockdown I was like, well I want to use my time wisely, so I started just doing American accent lessons.
And it served me well because I did three films with an American accent right after each other. Does it feel comfortable enough to you? You don't even have to think about it, you can just think about the acting? Well, the strangest thing was that I don't really have a process as such, and I want to be one of those people that does. But with an American accent, it sort of does give you that because I have to sit down and go through the whole thing
and have someone with me making sure I sound right. So it feels like it does feel like a process in a way. But I did two films in an English accent last year and thought, I cannot remember how to do this. And then I just did a film in an American accent and thought,, I cannot remember how to do this. And then I just did a film in an American accent and thought, I cannot fucking remember how to do this. So it's... So now you're lost, kind of in between, sort of.
Yeah, I'm like, who am I? You could go into mime work maybe instead. Is that a fix? When you work on an accent, so do you do it, were you doing it kind of... Well, obviously, like you said, you did during lockdown, and then you kind of work on it as you're leading up, and then work every day on that scene,
sort of as you're getting ready, working with the dialect coach? No, because I... And I think that's a COVID thing. I've only done one film with the dialect coach on set, and she was doing everyone. Right. So usually I prep on the Sunday, and then I do the week as is, sort of alone, I suppose. And then ADR is obviously helpful.
Daisy, do you lean on an acting coach or any acting kind of thing, person, for each role? Are you like, you know what, I got this, I did the work, I studied, I went to school for it, I know what I'm doing. I do not lean on anyone, and I've not worked with an acting coach. That's not to say I think I... You don't need it.
I mean, I'm sure I do need it. No, because some actors do, some actors don't, you know. And even those that use them might not need them, they just, they like the interface. Yes, exactly. They like that sort of partnership, I think. Yeah, yeah. I like to be very,
I do all my thinking and all my work, and then I like to come,... I do all my thinking and all my work and then I like to come and I'm quite a... I don't... I take my work very seriously. I do not take myself very seriously. So I like to... I'm quite a messer-abouter on set, I suppose. But I'm never like interrupting anyone else and obviously there are times where we can't do that. But I like to really just have a great time on set. You haven't worked with Tom yet, have you?
Well, just the film we met on. Ah, yeah, there's that. But we were not together then. So, no, and then he wrote the film we made last year. But he was filming based on a true story and we were filming here. And I think that would have been very difficult for him to have been on set, because I was acting and he was writing,
and I was like, oh my God, I think that would have made me very self-conscious. So you guys are doing the movie together. How early on in the film did you start to see the first spark, you know? Walk us through it, because I know Will loves a good rom-com, he just likes to know the meat cutes and everything.
So just go slow for him. I love a meat cute. Yeah. Well, another of your guests, Penelope Cruz, sort of takes credit for us being together. Does she? Really? Yeah. It was sort of we were like best friends.
That's how it starts. And then we were together. And then when we came back together for the premiere, Penelope, I'm not even gonna try and do her accent, but she said, your connection was so strong. Do it, try it right now. Your connection was so strong. That's great.
That's terrible, I'm so sorry. No, that's great. All Spanish people. That's really good. Yeah, so, but we were best friends immediately. Well, okay, so your best friend's on set, and there is, is he, do you get the sense that he is starting to feel like maybe things
are maybe gonna be better than friends? Oh my God, I've never talked about that. No, we're gonna walk right through this. Yeah, we have to. And then, were we, was the first, did like, did the first, was the first declaration of like, hey, I like, now you're talking to a guy, I've been married for 25 years.
The last relationship, it was like school, right? Where you're passing notes, for Christ's sake. I don't know how this stuff happens. I like you. Yeah, you know, will you go with me? Or whatever the hell we used to say. Go with me, yeah. So how did it happen?
Did you, did you pass him a note? Was it a little giggle after a take? What are we doing here? Accidentally brushing a hand. What are we doing? Yeah, let's get out of here. What's happening? Oh my God.
Do you want to share a ride to the hotel? Like tell me what happens, Daisy. So I want to know those answers. If you don't kiss me right now. Was it that clear? Daisy, come on. Daisy. Oh my God. I'll call Tom right now. I'll that clear? Daisy, come on. Daisy. Oh my God.
I'll call Tom right now. I'll get it from him. Or Daisy, how about this? Who asked who out first and what were the circumstances? Thank you, Sean. Oh my God. Oh my God, Tracy does not need to know. Tracy loves this.
Are you kidding me? Wisconsin's on fire right now. This is the only thing we've never had to explain to her. This is how much she loves it. Oh my God. I've literally read. It's very cute. All right, so let's just, we're gonna fill in for you. Okay, so we're gonna assume that we're midway through the shoot. It's about a 30-day shoot. So we're in, you know, second week or whatever.
And somebody's got a little issue with maybe a scene that's coming up. Maybe it's Daisy and she says, Tom, would you ever want to work on this? Maybe talk about it over coffee or dinner or something like that. Just with a straight face, like you could not care less, right? Because you're an actor, you're a professional liar. You're making him think like you couldn't care, like he's not your type. And then you guys get to the dinner, you're walking through the scene,
you both brought your pages, whatever. And then you just start laughing about growing up as kids and what a great last name he's got. Have you ever met him? Oh my gosh, you know, did it kinda go like that? I bet it did. The thing is, it's not that crazy. Oh my God, we were just best friends
and then we were together and now we're married. Who made the first move? Me. Oh. He did. He did, of course he did. We were best friends and then we moved together and now we're married. Who made the first move? He did. He did, of course he did. Good for him. We'll be right back. We get support from State Farm.
Nothing feels better than a personal win, right? From finishing a home DIY project, hitting a workout PR, or even just taking your car in for that oil change. If you define it as a win, it calls for a celebration. And who's cheering right beside you? State Farm. With the State Farm Personal Price Plan, you can create an affordable price just for you when you bundle home and auto. So celebrate by breaking out the confetti and those happy dance moves. Talk to a State Farm agent today to learn how you can bundle and save with a personal price plan.
Like a good neighbor, State Farm is there. Prices are based on rating plans that vary by state. Coverage options are selected by the customer. Availability, amount of discounts and savings, and eligibility vary by state. This episode of Smart List is brought to you in part by Skinny Pop Popcorn. Now, Skinny Pop Popcorn is something that is a part of my, you know, I mean, a lot of it goes in this face and I love it. And thank God it's somewhat, you know, it's right there in the title, it's Skinny. So, you know, if it weren't, there might be two of me because I do enjoy the stuff. Skinny Pop Original Popcorn is delicious and it's made with just three simple ingredients.
Gotta love that. In addition to their original popcorn, Skinny Pop offers a variety of delicious flavors ranging from cheddar jalapeno to sweet and salty kettle. Shop Skinny Pop now. multi-kettle. Shop Skinny Pop now. offering stock trading, IRAs, and many more products to over 23 million funded customers. With Robinhood, it's simple to make investments towards your future goals, whatever those may be. Maybe you want to work towards investing for your family's future, maybe a vacation this summer, or visiting every baseball stadium in the country. We all have some bucket list items to cross off, and Robinhood has tools to help us pursue them. You know, it's pretty cool to have the power of investment and trading on your phone in the palm of your hand. It sounds really, really cool.
As far as long-term investing, a small amount invested now could make a big difference 30 years down the road. Take your financial future by the reins, download the app, or visit robinhood.com to learn more. Investing involves risk and loss of principal is possible. Returns are not guaranteed. Robinhood Financial LLC member SIPC is a registered broker dealer. Smartless is brought to you in part by Airbnb. Scotty and I had a couple friends in recently,
actually more than two, and they rented an Airbnb because we didn't have the space for them. And we went over there and it was like beautiful. It was gorgeous. And I was like, wow, I can't believe people rent their places out like this. And they do because it's such a good idea. I don't know, maybe you've stayed in an Airbnb before
and thought to yourself, this actually seems pretty doable. Maybe my place could be an Airbnb. It could be as simple as starting with a spare room or your whole place when you're away. You could be sitting on an Airbnb and not even know it. Maybe you're planning a getaway this year. While you're away, you could Airbnb your home and make some extra money toward the trip.
Your home might be worth more than you think. Find out how much at airbnb.ca slash host. And now back to the show. So I want to talk a little bit about Young Woman in the Sea, which I tried to watch and I couldn't. But tell me about the prep for that. and then I want to talk about projects like, how do you choose what's important to you? The prep for Young Woman in the Sea was,
I could not swim a full length when I first started swim training. And then three months later, I was plonked in the Black Sea for nine days while we filmed the swim. In fact, the two attempts that Trudy made. You shot that in the Black Sea for nine days while we filmed the swim. In fact, the two attempts that Trudy made. You shot that in the Black Sea? Yeah.
Off the coast of? Bulgaria. Bulgaria, okay. Does that track well? That tracks, yeah. No, Sofia is the capital. Keep going. Yeah. Yeah.
So two and a half months swimming prep and then a shoot, which obviously was not all swimming, but a lot of swimming, and then ending with those nine days. So I was pretty tired after that. Yeah, you think you're in shape until you start swimming, right? I mean, swimming is just the hardest thing to do. I think you're endurance.
Yeah, I can't do it. I can't do it. I run out of breath so quickly, even from one lap in the pool. Is that right, Charm? Oh yeah, I literally came up halfway and was the first time and said I don't think I can do this. But my swimming coach is also an Olympian.
She won silver at Rio. So the whole time I was like... And now because we're friends, I introduce her as an Olympian and every time she's like, can you just not? But she's so amazing. Why did she not want to be known as an Olympian? Because she's so sweet and so modest. What's her name?
Siobhan Marie O'Connor. Siobhan Marie O'Connor. If you see her on the street and approach her and congratulate her on the Olympics. Yeah. That's so cool. So when you're working out with somebody like that, who is quite legit, like an Olympic swimmer, who's won medals, do you get motivated
by how good she is? You're like, I'm exhausted, but I don't want to let her down, so I'm just gonna keep going. Yeah, yeah. Also, she retired early because she got ill, and she was still swimming with her illness, so that's like a double whammy of unbelievable. Wow.
Yes, and also I knew, you know, you get to sit and you're like, well, this is what I signed up for. So I also didn't want to let anyone else down and I wanted to be able to do the thing even though... Sean got ill once swimming, but it's because he ate a pound of gummies too soon before he went in the pool. Full pound.
Yeah, couldn't sleep that night either. Sour Patch! Hey, Daisy, what's it like just bobbing in the open ocean, having to do a bunch of work for days and days and days? Didn't you think the odds of you having a little bit of a nudge from a large fish? Yeah. Pretty big, right? Well, I knew there were no sharks, but there are jellyfish.
How did you know that? Who told you that? What are they, Colin Sick? The Black Sea specialists told me that there were no sharks, but there were actual unexploded mines. Geez. Wait, wait, is that true? There's no sharks in the Black Sea?
No. But there are jellyfish and there are mines. And we were told that where we were, the mines had been exploded. And that was not comforting. That was... Wow, I've been exploding mines for a long time. Yeah. Oh, mines. M-I-E. Got it, got it, got it.
And each time it was really cold and very overwhelming, because you're fighting against the current, and then I had to keep pace with the follow boat that's in the film, and then I had to keep pace with the camera boat that's on the other side. And also I was afraid of open water. It's Jerry Bruckheimer that produced the film. And I did say to the producers and the writer and director, I am afraid of open water and I think they thought I was joking.
But like I wasn't joking. So each time I got in, I had to... Yeah, me too. How did you not just pass on the movie, being that that's one of your fears? Because I really wanted to do the movie. I mean, I did a film just before Christmas where I am a window cleaner. We were calling it Dye Shard. Were you scared of windows?
I'm terrified of cleaning windows. Height, I'll bet. I'm terrified of heights. There it is. Wait, Daisy, what were you calling it? You were calling it what? Dye Shard. Dye Shard, that's so good.
You know, a thing goes on and I, well I have to fight my way into the building and save the day, Allah, Allah die hard. But yeah, I'm afraid of heights. And at that point I thought, why do I keep doing this? But the roles are so good, you know? And it's a great time to overcome something. I love that, yeah, yeah. It's great.
I mean, were there moments where you're like, and I'm not kidding, were you like, how do I get out of this? Or were you like, never? Yeah, there were, and then, I mean do I get out of this? Or were you never? Yeah, there were. And then, I mean, the scariest moment of Young Woman in the Sea was when we were flying home after rap and the director, Joakim, said,
so basically, after the shot was over, I would have to get on like a life raft and then the safety boat would grab the life raft and pull me to safety, essentially. And Joakim said, oh, there was a time where your leg was dragging right under the propeller and I thought your leg was gonna be cut off. Oh, God.
Well, I guess it's better to know after the fact. Yeah, but no, it was all pretty scary. So you're looking for a nice sitcom right about now, yeah? Yeah, I'm looking for something more. Sitting down, having a nice time. about now, yeah? A little multi-cam studio audience. Yeah, sitting down, having a nice time. And just the trajectory of your career is so impressive from that pub to getting to Star Wars and now just working constantly with such impressive work
and being around so many people that know what they're doing and are at the top of their game. Is there, of those people you've worked with so far, is there some kind of advice somebody gave you at one point where just like, wow, and it really stuck with you? Or something that kind of moved you in a way that you're like, I gotta hang on to that? I had a dinner with someone who's quite big
in the film world, and he goes, your career is so interesting. And I was like, ah. And at the time I thought, is that a good thing? But actually I am not someone who has planned things out. I just know what I like and I go with what's available and that I like. So I am sort of, I'm trying not to look sideways
and doing my own thing. Yeah, so quote, your career is interesting wasn't great advice. It was just a comment. Well, it was a comment, but it made me think, oh, I mean, should I be more strategic? And actually I thought, no, because the stuff I've got to do has been very wide ranging. Like sometimes I thought, no, because the stuff I've got to do has been very wide ranging.
Like sometimes I think about dying, we made in 23 days with a tiny budget and it was as enriching as Star Wars, which is, you know, many, many, many times that, both budget and filming wise. That's interesting. Whatever you're doing, it's right. I mean, you're doing things that are challenging you
and we can't do anything about who's gonna see something, who it's for, where it's gonna be, when it's gonna be released, all that stuff. We just gotta do our job, right? And do the things that feed us. So it sounds like you're making the right decision. Ben Mendelsohn said something because I used to feel more, I suppose,
like it was my fault how something was going to perform or not. And Ben was like, we just do the work we do and then, that's it. You know, what more can you do? As Jason Bateman said to me decades ago, none of this is up to you. And that stuck with me forever. You only have one part in it all. Yeah. Daisy Ridley, what is Daisy Ridley doing in between gigs?
Because she works so much. What do you do with your time off? This week I'm going to see, though it's supposed to be a surprise, Sarah Snook in Dorian Gray on Thursday. We won't tell her. Okay, wow. I read, watch movies. We went to go see Monkey Man on...
Oh, I hear that's great. I want to see that. What is that? I haven't heard of that. It's great. Dev Patel, director, actor... Director, star. That's his first film he directed, right? It's... The action is sick.
It's really an impressive film. I have seen that. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Lots of hanging out, see my family impressive film. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Lots of hanging out, see my family a lot. See my nephews a lot. Kids have bigger family in the future for you and maybe some kids? Geez, what a really good person.
Maybe. I know, I'm like, wow, what am I thinking about that? I don't know, I'll just ask him. I'm obsessed with my nephews. I love them so much. How old are they? They are, the little ones are two and a half and six months.
And they're just delightful little squishy boys. I love that. Well, Daisy, it's now much later in the UK. You've been such a joy to be here today. Thank you for doing this. I know, you've been so generous. Huge fan, like crazy fan. Sean won Star Wars, Sean won Star Wars question.
We'll let you have one. You know what, go wake up Scotty and tell him to get over here and ask a question. Don't worry, he beamed Scotty up a while ago. Hey-o. Hey-o. No, I mean I had tons of Star Wars questions. Well then let's see one.
Which is the best one. Well, okay, let me just look. Oh my God, you really have them all written down. I do, I wrote them down. When you were on Endalore. Okay, so, no, I have a question about the test process, but you kind of talked about that. I have a question about, oh, here's one.
It has a massive fan base, Star Wars, obviously I'm one of them, but how does it feel to be part of such a beloved franchise and like do you feel a responsibility towards, you know, the fans? Like did you feel the weight of that? And were you a fan before? I would not have called myself a fan from before, no. I had seen some of them.
And then when I was auditioning I was like, oh, this is everywhere. And it was one of those things of suddenly there was... So you didn't know that before? You were like, oh, this is everywhere. You're making Sean angry. No, no, it was... I mean I was aware of it. But you know when you're auditioning for something it is very present in your world. That it's there and you want the thing.
And I remember seeing a Princess Leia t-shirt. I thought, oh, okay. And then every book I read, there was a reference. In every film I watched, there was a reference. So it was one of those things. And then the love grew. But also I think that was good because I was... Cool it. Yeah, easy. I was just...
Like I was so wondrously happy to be there. But because I didn't quite understand how far-reaching it was. Did you know that it's... He's not Baby Yoda. He's actually a different name, but everybody calls him Baby Yoda. By the way, can you see it? Have you got one up there? Can you see him up there? Right in the back, up there? Oh, sweet.
What's he called, Sean? His... Oh, God. Birth name. Grogu. Gro Oh, sweet. What's he called, John? His, oh God. Birth name. Grogu. Grogu, yeah. It's actually Grogu. I was put on the spot, I was so nervous. I know you are, Angel.
Careful of your heart, okay? Can I ask you one more question about it? Where are the paddles? What? Can I ask you one more question about it? Please. And then, so. We're so sorry, Daisy.
When it, after it came out, were you like, the rush of it, like what was the downside after it? Like, because the announcement of it, the announcement of the cast, and then the shooting of it, and then it came out, and all of it was so massive, and then you rapped, and then what is that moment like?
I mean, the rap at the very end was, someone has it recorded somewhere. I was crying so much it was hilarious. I couldn't speak. I was going, I'm having such a good time. Like I was one of those wailing people that was looking around at these wondrous people that had been there for 18 months of my life.
Oh my God. That was very emotional. But was there a sense of like, what the hell am I gonna do next? Like, what am I gonna do now? Oh yeah. Yeah, yeah. Because that January after we were all, oh yeah.
The January after they were all done, it just felt so quiet. Like, you know, you just spend all your time with, and particularly on press tours, when you're with people all hours of the day, that was very strange. And then we went into lockdown. So that was all like a very strange experience
of having to sit quietly. Must have just been like, wow, like the sets and the costumes, like it's just amazing to me. And then last one, can you give me anything at all that Cathy Kennedy told you about the movie? I know you haven't read the script yet, but any kind of nugget, anything, anything
about Ray in the next movie? I'll be in it. No. How about this? Would you be possibly open to, subject to the rules of the set and everything, of Sean, and maybe me and Will... Stormtrooper.
No, no, showing up on set doing a bit of a remote episode of a very special Star Wars smart list on set. We interview you, maybe JJ can pop by, I mean, whoever else. Yeah? I mean, I feel really Are you sure? Yeah? I mean, I feel really bad because the only person I ever had... Oh, morning Mr. McPie. I had visit in a friend through work, where was Josh Gad. And he came the day...
The scene was that I was Palpatine's granddaughter. And he literally said, you ruined my fucking life. It was like, why did you bring me today? And I just didn't think. No, I get it. Because wait, your pulpit is for ranzar. And I felt so riddled with guilt. Riddled with guilt?
Yeah. I was riddled with guilt. So now I'm so scared. I don't want to ruin anything for anyone. Wait, no, but you can't say anything about that. Don't get her fired. Shia, no, I just, but there's gotta be something that you can give that doesn't give anything away.
Look, I won't press. Some time has passed. Some time in the past. Wait, something in the past? No, no, some time has passed. Oh, some time has passed. Yes, and you said some time in the past. I think it is in the past.
Oh, really? And I think we might film next year. Might film next year. Okay, we've got it. That's enough, that's enough. That's at least something. But anyway, Daisy. Start laying out your outfit now, Sean.
I feel like she might. I think I have part of it on. I have underoos on. Star Wars underoos. Daisy, you're such a pleasure. Thank you for being here. Youos on. I thought it was underoos. Daisy, you're such a pleasure. Thank you for being here. You really are.
Thank you so much for doing this. Such a joy. Please say hi to Tom. Thank you. I will do. Absolutely love you and love everything about you. Thanks, guys. Thanks, Daisy.
Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. She's the sweetest. I love how cute she was when we asked her about how they met and how she turned her husband. Certain things are private, okay?
And then you get to just fill in the blanks, like I did, and we wrote our little airport romance novel. We did pry, we did pry for sure. But yeah, it must be, I love watching what she's doing after, you know, ASW, after Star Wars, to create a career for herself and all these other. It doesn't need an acronym at all. It's not a thing.
Yeah. Okay. But all of these movies that she's done is really kind of stretching her skills, and it's awesome to see because she knocks it out of the park every time. She's balancing like that big, huge, global commercial thing with like these great small independent films as well and the stuff in the middle.
Like prestige films in between. Like, yeah, yeah, yeah. It's the way to do it. Sweet girl. And maybe the best name in Hollywood. Daisy Ridley. That's a hard one to beat. Daisy Ridley.
It's so tremendous. What a name. Isn't it? Oh, by the way, you guys, Young Woman in the Sea is in theaters right now. I'm excited for that. I do want to see that. I mean, I'm scared as well of that.
Open Water, even watching somebody like those films. Did you ever see the movie Open Water? No. What was the one? Isn't that Nicole Kidman? Yeah, Nicole Kidman, Sam Neill. No, that was... What was that one from years ago?
Below Deck. Dead Calm. Below Deck. On Bravo. Oh, it's Below Deck. Yes, B-E-L. I thought it was Below, okay. Sorry, it was a different show.
It's about a guy I dated named Dick. All right, so, no, but Open Water, the movie, did you ever see the movie Open Water? It's based on a true story about the scuba divers. And the scuba divers all go down and they all come back up and the boat counters like, okay, this couple's back, this couple's back, and the boat takes off and they leave a couple in the ocean
underneath snorkeling still or whatever, and they come up and they fucking, they're in the middle of open water. Rude, it's just rude. That's right, anyways. And what do they do? What happens, Sean? They get, of course, they meet their demise
by sharks and everything. Truly? Yeah. I think it's based on a true story. I met people on that thing. How do they know? How do they know what happened? Oh, how terrible.
So you sit there, you watch them bobbing in the ocean for an hour and a half, and then they get eaten, and you can go ahead, roll credits? It's based on a true story. I met people on it. How do they know? How do they know what happened? Oh, how terrible. So you sit there, you watch them bobbing in the ocean for an hour and a half, and then they get eaten, and you can go ahead and roll credits? Yes, but it's like, it's really intense. It's really scary. Wow. Anyway.
I could skip that. How did they have the time to write the screenplay before they died? Because if they say it's a true story, how the fuck do we know? They had an iPhone. They had an iPhone. Nice try.
Nice try. Nice try. But thank God Daisy Ridley is all good from the Black Sea and nothing happened to her. But anyway. So who's working on a bi? I mean I think everybody's always working on a bi. But don't ask why. Everybody's working on a bi. And then...
Since the dawn of time. You know where I read it? I read it in the Bible. Bible. Nice, we've never used that. Amen. Bible, Bible. Smart.
Less. Smart. Less. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armjarff, Bennett Barbicoe, and Michael Grant Terry. If you like SmartList, you can listen early and ad free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple podcasts. Prime members can listen ad free on Amazon Music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wondry.com slash survey.
Scammers are best known for living the high life until they're forced to trade it all in for handcuffs and an orange jumpsuit once they're finally caught. I'm Saatchi Cole. And I'm Sarah Haggye. And we're the host of Scamfluencers, a weekly podcast from Wondery that takes you along the twists and turns of some of the most infamous scams of all time,
the impact on victims, and what's left once the facade falls away. We've covered stories like a Shark Tank certified entrepreneur who left the show with an investment, but soon faced mounting bills, an active lawsuit filed by Larry King, and no real product to push. He then began to prey on vulnerable women instead, selling the idea of a future together while stealing from them behind their backs.
To the infamous scams of Real Housewives stars like Teresa Giudice, what should have proven to be a major downfall only seemed to solidify her place in the Real Housewives Hall of Fame. Follow Scamfluencers on the Wendree app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to Scamfluencers early and ad-free right now on Wendree+. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.